you're widely considered uh the number
one i think independent financial
advisor uh in the country and so when
you started to uh become curious about
bitcoin cryptocurrencies uh and these
technologies and then eventually uh what
i would categorize as uh kind of a
rational proponent uh for these
technologies uh it caught my eye i would
say oh wow like that's a very very big
deal that rick edelman is now uh
interested in this stuff where are you
in kind of that enthusiasm for uh these
technologies and and how do you think
about bitcoin or other assets within
just the average americans financial
portfolio today
well i've been as you know pumped been
focusing on
what's next what's coming where we
headed throughout my entire career i'm
regarded as a futurist in the financial
industry and my last book the truth
about your future uh was all focused on
exponential technologies ai robotics 3d
printing big big data nanotech biotech
bioinformatics where all these
technologies taking us what are the
investment opportunities and how are
they going to impact our lives careers
college planning housing marriage estate
planning and so on and that's why i
wrote that book back in 2017 and most of
its predictions have now come true it
included a prediction about the predator
about the pandemic that we would have
one by 2020 uh and so
we have to recognize that this is all
changing rapidly because of
technological innovation and now a big
key element of that is blockchain and
digital assets which has caused me to
write my new book
the uh the truth about crypto um you
know you you begin with uh the truth
about your future which mentioned crypto
and now an entire book the truth about
crypto which just came out last week and
debuted at number one at amazon i'm
really excited about how well it's being
received we have to recognize that this
is the first new asset class as you know
in 170 years the last time we had a new
asset class was the discovery of oil in
the 1850s and look how incredibly
impactful oil has been on the globe
you know prior to oil we were using
whale oil to light our candles look at
us today and that's where we are now
with the innovation of blockchain and
digital assets this is a huge deal it's
going to be the biggest source of wealth
generation over the next 20 years than
any other asset class probably more
impactful than any other asset class in
history and in a truncated period won't
take 100 years to have an impact like
oil did it's going to have an incredible
impact within a decade already has
and this next eight years are going to
be amazing so i finally felt compelled
that if i want to help investors i want
to help consumers around the country
improve their ability to achieve
financial security
and pay their way for kids into college
buying a home caring for aging parents
the most impactful way that i can help
you do this is by helping you understand
crypto
to the point where i have walked away
from edelman financial the company that
my wife and i built over the last 40
years to as you noted the largest
investment advisory firm in the country
with 300 billion dollars in assets under
management i walked away from it because
i can be more impactful to you i can
help you better
by teaching you about crypto than any
other single thing i might be able to do
in the book you talk about basically
four major uh breakthrough inventions
fire the wheel the internet and then
eventually the blockchain technology
that solved the double spend problem i
want to start uh obviously just with the
gravity of that framework right fire the
wheel uh things that people just take
for granted today uh you put this
technology there walk me through a
little bit as to why you believe it's
that important
yeah i'm trying to hit people upside the
head uh to get your attention and to
make you realize just pay attention this
is a big deal i mean to suggest that
blockchain is on the same level as the
wheel i mean you know it's a barney fife
moment you got to be kidding me
and that's really the point that i'm
trying to make is that just as the wheel
changed everything our discovery of fire
changed everything the invention of the
airplane the the invention of the uh the
the phonograph and the
um
uh you name it just the the incredible
inventions the assembly line that henry
ford uh invented these things changed
everything and that's what blockchain
technology is doing we all know how
incredibly impactful the internet was
the ability for us to transmit uh our
words to somebody else instantly and for
free you know via an email our ability
to connect with friends online via
facebook that was the original internet
the connection of people well then we
have the internet of things you know my
phone talks to my car
now we have the internet of money the
ability to move money around the world
as easily as we send a text doing it as
cheaply and safely as securely and as
transparently this is huge for global
commerce because businesses are always
trying to figure out how can i move
faster safer and cheaper and that's what
blockchain technology is all about and
if you think this isn't going to be a
huge deal you just ain't you're not
paying attention give you one
illustration i mean we all heard the
statistics would you know that 90
percent of the world's banks are
developing blockchain technology my
favorite data point is this last year
bank of america all by itself
filed 161
patent applications
how can you
i didn't even know there were that many
things to invent in this field first of
all um that's just one bank one year
vcs are putting about a third of all
their money into blockchain technology
you can't spend a hundred billion
dollars over a five-year period and end
up with nothing to show for it the
incredible impact is going to be huge
and the sooner people learn about this
and understand why this is a big deal
for business and how it's going to be
impactful and the investment
opportunities that are available the
sooner people figure that out
the more wealth they're going to be able
to create but bitcoins already thirty
thousand dollars look at how much you've
you've already missed how much more of
it are you gonna miss before you finally
say
i need to add it to my portfolio